do you want to talk about how you'd fart
well yeah that's like oh good you
brought it up i was actually going to
read that passage here in the front of
the book
i can just tell the story no no no no no
no no i want this is because this is in
print this is the library of congress
has this for all as long as there's an
america this will exist in our nation's
records okay
good what i got this is during the
pandemic wasn't so much a sweeping view
of american politics because there was
no campaign
as a slightly claustrophobic
appreciation of love and my particular
marriage i learned for example
how to keep a straight face on live tv
as my husband burped farted and or
napped feet away from my camera position
there was one often right on the floor
no wait the dig let me tell the story
let me tell the story in full because i
didn't tell him well here's no but here
like this just is exactly how you know
i'm a network television anchor i know
you this is how you describe me okay
often right on the floor i'm napping
just right on the ground burping farting
sleeping during the day
so both of our cameras are down there
you're down there sleeping on the floor
for some reason not on a couch or in our
bed you are deciding to sleep on the
floor now the only place that kids
wouldn't go i think it's because you
wanted to be closer to me you missed me
during the day i wanted to i wanted the
yes that's it that's exactly right so
i'm on camera i'm i'm interviewing i
think i'm doing a really hard interview
a very sad interview in the middle of
the pandemic everything is awful
and
and you are sitting in a plastic chair
off to my side you just like you're
alone let one rip and it reverberates
off the plastic like you're doing it
into a speaker and the whole room can
hear it i'm positive that you could hear
it through my microphone and not only
that but it smelled horrible so i have
to sit there and desperately try not to
laugh
during a really tough interview so thank
you very much and then you wouldn't
cross by the camera because the bathroom
wasn't in the commercial break and then
like use the bathroom and leave the door
open
and then flush it as the graphic swirl
that came back to me
and i just remember thinking like you
dummy all right i'm gonna i'm gonna
i don't even know what we're definitely
not using any of this right this is all
getting cut this is definitely getting
this is all good this is gonna be a clip
for this is all twitter right
you